now let's explore manage serverless
computing
the final application platform that
you'll explore in this section of the
course is cloud run
Cloud run is a managed compute platform
that lets you run stateless containers
by using web requests or Pub sub events
Cloud run is serverless
that means that it removes all
infrastructure management tasks so you
can focus on developing applications
it's built on k-native an open API and
runtime environment built on kubernetes
that gives you freedom to move your
workloads across different environments
and platforms
it can be fully managed on Google Cloud
on Google kubernetes engine or anywhere
k-native runs
Cloud run is fast
it can automatically scale up from zero
and back down almost instantaneously and
it charges you only for the resources
you use calculated down to the nearest
100 milliseconds so you'll never pay for
your over-provisioned resources
the cloud run developer workflow is a
straightforward three-step process
first you write your application using
your favorite programming language this
application should start a server that
listens for web requests
second you build and package your
application into a container image
and finally you deploy the container
image to Cloud run
after you've deployed your container
image you'll receive a unique https URL
back which you will use to run your new
containerized application
Cloud run then starts your container on
demand to handle requests and ensures
that all incoming requests are handled
by dynamically adding and removing
containers
Cloud run is serverless and that means
that you as a developer can focus on
building your application and not on
building and maintaining the
infrastructure that powers your
application
for some use cases a container-based
workflow is great because it gives you a
great amount of transparency and
flexibility
if you build the container image you
have the power to decide exactly what
file is added to your container image
and how it gets there
however building an application is hard
enough already let alone having to think
about containerization and the
responsibilities that come with that
sometimes you're just looking for a way
to turn source code into an https
endpoint and you want your vendor to
make sure that your container image is
secure well configured and built in a
consistent way
with Cloud run you can do both you can
use a container-based workflow and a
source-based workflow
if you use the source-based approach
you'll deploy your source code instead
of a container image
Cloud run then builds your source and
packages the application into a
container image for you
cloudron does this by using build packs
an open source project
Cloud run handles https serving for you
that means you only have to worry about
handling web requests and you can let
Cloud run take care of adding the
encryption
by default your application is exposed
on a unique subdomain of the global
run.app domain
you can also use your own custom domain
Cloud run manages everything else
generating a valid SSL certificate
configuring SSL termination correctly
with secure settings
and handling incoming requests
decrypting them and forwarding them to
your application
the pricing model on cloud run is unique
you only pay for the system resources
you use while a container is handling
web requests with a granularity of 100
milliseconds and when it's starting or
shutting down
you do not pay for anything if your
container does not handle requests
additionally there is a small fee for
every 1 million requests you serve
the price of container time increases
with CPU and memory
a container with more vcpu and memory is
more expensive
today Cloud run can allocate up to four
vcpus and eight gigabytes of memory
most of the other compute products such
as compute engine charge for servers as
long as they are running even if you're
not using them
this means you're often paying for idle
server capacity
you can use cloud run to run any binary
as long as it's compiled for Linux
64-bit
now this means you can use cloud run to
run web applications written using
popular languages such as Java python
node.js PHP
go and C plus
you can also run code written in less
popular languages like Cobalt Haskell
and Pearl
as long as your app handles web requests
you should be able to run it and scale
it automatically using Cloud run